he's got 37
overcoming the throw picked up brown
the other way hold on here comes here
comes middleton
but
brown slowed down and that gave a chance
for middleton to catch up
he made a play
trying to go after the ball here he
slowed down brown sees him in his rear
view mirror
[Applause]
it's just a har foul
look he gets the arm
[Applause]
he was going for the ball
[Applause]
and it's the optics that make it look
bad do you have a bigger guy chasing
down a smaller guy
i mean but this is a scary fall don't
get me wrong
that is a scary fall
question is
will this be
middleton picked up his fourth foul
listen to the thump right here
[Applause]
brown's a tough one yes
brown
tonight
with 19 points he's hit three threes his
shooting has just been
off the charts the best shooting stretch
of his four-year career is right now
and he credits
assistant coach kyle korver for his
improved shooting question is does
middleton kind of sling him to the
ground which held his elbow
a little bit
again we we have the luxury of super
slow here's the foul obviously
i
i just think this is a common foul
they'll probably be
bumped up to a flagrant one
but this is a hard foul
and maybe this may be bringing them down
right there
i can see where that could be a flagrant
one and i think that's what they're
probably going to look at
in what reggie to you and i has seemed
like a dress rehearsal for the playoffs
yes this has had that kind of feel and
finish to it and both teams obviously
have a lot to play for yes
a flagrant foul penalty two has been
assessed wow
well a defensive player as well let's
say that too
going up for the dunk
held onto the arm held onto the arm
and brown easily
could have broke an arm on this fall
here
and we're talking we're talking about a
player who has just taken his
shooting numbers to a whole different
level three-point in particular
he was below 30 percent shooting from
three